[Music]  hi I'm just I'm looking for a check  mm-hmm who's asking John chef jr. your  son my son jr. yeah  [Music]  you know they said that cash shed is a  bad mother ship now ignore him  thinks he's a black James Bond that dude  was real you think it was me babysit  your head never long enough lady  syphilis  madam chlamydia it's lovely to meet you  both that's doing it well she'll look  better please tell me that you did not  get out son involved in your [ __ ]  picked up a bet you can't beat up a  woman or not because misogynistic won't  be misogynistic  I ain't mention agenda okay I'm an  equal-opportunity asked what  [Music]  right such you okay yeah  walk back in a day we didn't need  console we need to go south bare-knuckle  Heil well you can't be too prepared let  me get you back to having an iPhone oh  hell do I shut it damn right what's up  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]